i have good news and bad news to start
with today
and they're both the same depending on
your perspective
donald trump last night gave what is
likely to be his last rally ever as
president of the united states
if you like the trump craziness it's
coming to an end if you dislike it it's
coming to an
end so it's good or bad depending on
your perspective it was bizarre
it was deranged it was also really
boring and it took place
in georgia the point of the rally
supposedly was to support the two
republican senators running in today's
elections kelly lefler and david perdue
but down to every detail the entire
event was a
farce david perdue couldn't even be at
the rally
because he's in coronavirus quarantine
of the nearly 90 minutes that donald
trump ranted
almost none of it was about the senate
candidates it was mostly
about trump much of it telling lie after
lie
it is not an exaggeration to say donald
trump told hundreds of lives during
yesterday's rally insisting he won at
one point simply citing
supposed county level vote count numbers
from election night the crowd completely
silent for long stretches of the rally
and down to the last element i mean even
trump's face
more orange than we've ever seen it
despite his pale hands
every detail could not have been more
absurd and as i like to say
indistinguishable from satire so let's
get right into it
um here is donald trump within seconds
opening up the rally by lying about the
results in georgia
well i want to thank you very much hello
georgia by the way
there's no way we lost georgia there's
no way
the rig that was a rigged election
but we're still fighting it and you'll
see what's going to happen we'll talk
about it and
and this was the theme trump moments
later saying
if democrats take the white house and
then realizing hold on a second no no no
they're not taking it we won if the
liberal democrats take the senate of the
white house
and they're not taking this white house
we're gonna fight like hell i'll tell
you right now
and the theme was that the crowd really
didn't seem to care very much
about lefleur and purdue they seemed
to just be there for trump but even
trump got too boring for them for long
stretches and they tuned out which we'll
get to
donald trump then alluding to once again
hoping
that mike pence can steal the election
for him tomorrow
and i hope mike pence comes through for
us i have to tell you
i hope that our great vice president
our great vice president comes through
for us he's a great guy
of course if he doesn't come through i
won't like him quite as much
so this is wild for two reasons first
that donald trump is publicly pressuring
the vice president
to steal the election and second that
donald trump
seems to believe that mike pence can
steal the election pence's role in
washington dc tomorrow as we talked
about yesterday
is really perfunctory and we're all
going to see that tomorrow so i won't
get get ahead of myself
here is an example of donald trump
ranting about things nobody in the crowd
seemed to understand and the crowd is
silent at one point i wondered
did the crowd leave but they were there
just not making a peep
and you've got to swarm it tomorrow now
the good thing about tomorrow it's one
state so you have a lot of eyeballs
watching it's
tougher than when you have 50 states and
they do it
to various various states i never say
they like it
you know i was leading in pennsylvania
by
hundreds of thousands of votes all of a
sudden i was tired i said what happened
they'll make washington dc and other
liberal places
the 51st 52nd 53rd states of the union
guaranteeing
you can almost hear the room tone louder
than you can hear the crowd it's it's
really wild how dead silent trump was
able to get this crowd to be
trump then defiantly clarifying he does
not concede
even though he did lose two months ago
after all nothing and no one will be
able to stop them
the senate seats are truly the
last line of defense now i must preface
that by saying because they'll say he
just conceded
no no i don't think so
that got the crowd awake trump not
conceding that's the one thing he should
be doing and mentioning that is what
really gets the crowd fired up
so then this is funny when donald trump
did talk about david perdue and kelly
lefler which was almost not at all but
that was the point of the rally
in theory the crowd is totally bored
when trump talks about purdue and
leffler here he is talking about david
perdue
who it wasn't even clear whether trump
knew purdue wasn't there because he was
quarantining
doesn't matter you'll see the camera if
you're watching pan around and although
the
lack of masks is notable the lack of
enthusiasm is as well
over the last four years david perdue
has been one of our greatest allies and
strongest offenders in washington he's a
great gentleman and then the crowd just
as bored
when trump was talking about kelly
leffler just barely a cheer
georgia has another fantastic champion
in senator kelly lefler kelly is a
staunch defender of our
incredible military i'm so proud of our
military she supports the wall
and she always stands with the heroes of
law enforcement ice
usually they pump up the crowd noise i
was wondering whether they were
suppressing the crowd noise and that's a
joke
they weren't the crowd was just that
silent for much of this rally a deflated
empty speech
the cringiest moment in the whole thing
was
probably this moment when donald trump
called up
republican senate candidate kelly lefler
to the stage
and she had an announcement to make
which was that
tomorrow she will object object
to the counting of the electoral votes
that got the crowd uh interested they
woke up for that
hello georgia
thank you georgia i have an announcement
georgia
on january 6th i will object to the
electoral college vote
that's right that's right
thank you what energy right i mean just
the the energy just oozing off of kelly
lefler there
loudly announcing she will also be
making a fool out of herself in
washington dc tomorrow
and trump then seemed to be visibly
struggling
to get to the end of his speech you're
going to hear him sort of slurring here
mixing up words the last 20 minutes were
just one of the
most uh uh poorly delivered speeches
that i've seen from trump and that says
a lot
we have all seen what our opponents are
capable of doing
i ran two elections i won both of them
second one much more successful than the
first
but we can't let this happen any longer
on election night
we were leading by so much we're not
going to have that tomorrow
so then this is the part that's really
nuts
for about 20 straight minutes
trump read with terrible inflection and
tone
alleged voting results from various
counties and here he is wanting to talk
about maricopa county
arizona but he's only only able to get
out the word maya copa
and it doesn't even matter because
everybody's tuned out by this point
anyway
this is constituents reported that their
early or in-person ballots may not have
been correctly processed or tabulated in
myacopa county officials yeah so this
was the part that had the crowd
completely checked out just droning on
like this for 20 minutes here's another
part of it
you could really hear a pin drop in this
place the committee then heard
additional testimony concerning
voting irregularities during the 2020
general election
including testimony and a real-time test
demonstrating serious irregularities
with dominions voting machines
three events discussed at this hearing
stand out and require a forensic order
of the dominion
voting machines in georgia to be
immediately conducted
the one phrase that woke people back up
was trump
mentioning dominion voting machines the
sycophants have almost been trained in a
pavlovian manner
if you hear dominion that you have to
react to but they were really struggling
to remain even remotely engaged with
trump droning on and on about votes and
ballots
and then during his wind-up sort of
crescendo
uh trump actually glitches on the word
america and he tries to cover it up by
flexing his bicep
we have made america strong again look
at that
arm trump commonly does this we saw this
dozens and dozens of times during his
presidency when he
sort of glitches out during a word he'll
do something physical
to distract from it he'll flex his arm
or he'll slap the lectern a couple of
times or he'll turn to the other side of
the audience and say whoa hey how about
that
so trump's final rally as expected
all about himself he seemed sort of
to try to go through the motions of
talking about david perdue and kelly
lefler
but he really couldn't do it and what he
did do is spend a lot of time claiming
that he won in november
we are very close to the end very very
close
and the next question is what will trump
do
between tomorrow when the electoral
votes are counted
and january 20th when joe biden is sworn
in
will we see him at all will he tweet
will he go crazy tweeting will he not
tweet at all
we don't know but you can join me
tonight live
on youtube twitch and facebook for
georgia
senate results starting somewhere in the
7pm
eastern hour and then tomorrow at 1pm
eastern join me live on youtube twitch
and facebook
for the counting of the electoral votes
supposedly
the last stand for the trumpists
tomorrow 1pm eastern
join me tonight and join me tomorrow so
it's a new year
and for many people that means new goals
around getting fit or losing weight and
if part of that for you
involves a low-carb or ketogenic diet
then i have something you will want to
check out it's called
so keto-licious and they're giving you
20
off soaky delicious has perfected
ketogenic crusts for baking your
favorite foods
they make a delicious keto dessert crust
which comes in a chocolate
and vanilla flavor and it's perfect for
making things like pies they also have a
premium keto pizza crust which i've been
using at home to make pizzas and it's
great
it is great to go right out of the
freezer
and when you cook it it doesn't fall
apart like a lot of other low carb
crusts do
it's high fat which is perfect for keto
grain free gluten free no soy or
additives or
preservatives or fillers but most
importantly
they just taste great i can tell you
first hand just go to davidpakman.com
pizza the link is underneath this video
and they'll give you 20
off your entire order when you use the
coupon code pacman